but first freedom convoy protesters
protesting peacefully on the side of the
road in ontario after police were called
in to clear those who were blocking the
bridge over to detroit police making
about 12 arrests and the windsor police
department saying quote the arrested
persons are all facing a charge of
mischief
and of course the media is piling on the
trucker convoy the latest the new york
times pondering why some canadians are
asking hasn't he just ordered in the
police or the army to quash the
demonstrations
okay well ordering in the army wow i
wish the new york times would have had
that same reaction to the summer of 2020
rights but i digress leo i gotta get
your professional opinion on this um
these folks that have been arrested are
being charged with what they they call
mischief now it sounded a little dennis
the menace to me whenever i first heard
it sounded kind of like a broad sort of
minor charge but it is actually
punishable with up to 10 years
in prison um and it usually follows
vandalism of some variety these people
have been very peaceful um so kind of
makes you wonder about that but what are
your thoughts is this going to deter
any of the the trucker convoy the
protesters there from stopping
you know what laura i say yes and no i
think look at them they're very peaceful
i think you you're finding out that the
government do not want these what i call
very very peaceful protesters to bring
up the issue of these tyrannical
government mandates it's all about
mandates and what you see these
canadians doing has impacted the entire
world and i'm so glad you brought up the
2020 uh rice in this country and the new
york times they didn't call for the army
they didn't call for the police i want
to be clear and the fox viewers know
this there were murders
arson vandalism people constantly
committing crimes and the left looked
the other way and they go after these
protesters the motivation is simple
because these individuals are fighting
against federal mandates and government
control and you know what it doesn't fit
the left agenda i am proud of these
protesters
yeah i mean i think a lot of people
honestly are cheering them on not just
in canada here in america all over the
world you're right leo they're standing
up for freedom that is ultimately what
this is all about and you know joey they
might get them off the bridge right they
might move them out of the roadway but
these truckers do have another option
what if they just decide we're not going
to drive our trucks anymore i mean that
is an option they have too and then what
happens then what avenue is the
government in canada going to take to to
stop them and get them back on the road
that's a great question and that is an
option it's probably the next option i
think i think what we can understand
here is an effective protest doesn't
necessarily have to stay effective in
the way you're protesting in other words
they've they've done the damage they've
raised the the flag they've sounded the
alarm and they have canadians interested
in this issue in a way they probably
weren't before i think something that's
important to notice here is that when we
look at our own american liberal media
and pundits responding to this there's a
theme here which is that you know
fundamental uh principles don't get to
just be convenient they really believe
that because they they being the liberal
media they think that because they're so
um they're so set on believing that mass
mandates and vaccines are the right
thing to do that you can kind of risk or
gamble principles to make that happen
they think that they're being pragmatic
in that way when in fact the thing about
principles is they don't get to be
comfortable they just have to be
consistent and as a conservative when
the when the protests turned to riots in
this country without a lot of personal
connection to that issue that they were
writing about i said on this channel
time and time again i support their
protest i support their voice i support
them walking down the middle of the
street because i want to learn about
that issue but what i don't support is
burning down federal buildings causing
harm and hurting people that's not
what's happening here that's called
being principled and i would ask the
same of my liberal colleagues if i had
the opportunity
yeah well it seems uh that the folks
here in the united states uh in charge
of so much especially white house
homeland security advisor dr liz
sherwood randall is concerned she says
in a statement we are working closely
with our canadian counterparts to end
the blockade of key bridges and
crossings between the united states and
canada and to restore vital commerce
between our two nations we discussed the
widespread damaging impacts the
obstructions have already had on the
lives and livelihoods of people in both
our nations and the imperative of taking
swift strong action and
deterring future blockades um you know
it it seems like you look at these
people they don't look to be that big of
a threat and you know we've both joey
and leo you both talked about the fact
that the reaction was so different here
in america in the summer of 2020 when
aisha you've talked multiple times about
how frightened you were yourself going
out to cover those riots in new york
city
obviously there were people all over our
country who felt threatened because
cities were literally being burned to
the ground and the interest now being
taken by the liberal media and uh by our
own government seems rather interesting
considering it's not even happening in
our country and clearly these people
don't seem to be that big of a threat
but i do want to just go back to the guy
in charge there in canada justin trudeau
because he's been very outspoken against
these truckers right but how about this
tweet from march 31 2020 he says this
while many of us are working from home
there are others who aren't able to do
that like the truck drivers who are
working day and night to make sure our
shelves are stocked so when you can
please hashtag thank a trucker for
everything they're doing and help them
however you can aisha
what changed here he was so pro truckers
not too long ago
all of a sudden these are the worst
people in this country what happened
and i tell you those tweets will get you
every time you got to be careful look um
i'm glad we're talking about canada
what's happening there but i'm more
interested in what happens here because
these convoys
it sounds like are going to start
popping up in the u.s and i'm interested
to see
what the reaction is going to be because
we're already hearing from different
governors from blue states like michigan
new york that are very concerned about
what might happen governor whitmer up in
michigan calling these protests
dangerous so i'm interested to see what
happens and i think that this could
really turn into a big midterm issue
especially because the environment has
changed i don't know if you're paying
attention to what is happening in the
state of new york and specifically new
york city you've got democrats right
liberals who are fed up with these
mandates and what's happening with the
city you've got this new york mom now if
you've been following the story with
about mod [ __ ] who is now going to be
running for congress to try to unseat
long-time congresswoman carolyn maloney
i mean that tells you something is
shifting so i want to see what happens
when these things start popping up if
one heads over to the capital
how is
the state the city going to respond to
these convoys here in the united states
because i think it will
change or shift the outcome of the
midterms coming up people are very
frustrated
people are frustrated and leo i'm just
going to go back to you real quick with
justin trudeau you know he kind of has
himself in a tough spot here obviously
we see the the hypocritical tweet he had
there and aisha's right they'll always
come back to haunt you but you know he
could just meet with some of these
truckers hear them out but i guess it
feels like he's gonna cave and maybe is
this all just politics for him is that
why we've seen no movement on his end
is it all politics yes laura it is all
politics and he can't cave in because
that would be doing the right thing
these truckers have a legitimate claim
and i want to go back to what i just
said you know what when these democrats
when these truckers were out there when
there was no vaccine like the
firefighters like the first responders
like the police officer like the nurses
look what the government is how they're
treating them now they're throwing them
under the bus they're throwing all these
people who risked their lives to help us
now under the bus because it doesn't fit
their agenda laura
so sad to see you're exactly right all
right well we're gonna keep an eye on
this hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else